hey I want to mention something you have
a new podcast thank you with Ken Jong
yes I didn't give it to you it's just
your podcast Oh
and you talk about everything on this
from you'll talk about episodes of
community but you'll also talk about
coronavirus you come yell ken is a real
doctor or he used to be before he is he
how dare you he I'm sorry but so so he's
a dr. Phil he's a dr. oz I mean no he's
doctors out there spouting [ __ ] and
now supposed to believe that ken Jeong
is a real doctor well he went to Duke
Medical School he was a practicing
medical doctor so I know that I don't
think dr. Phil's an actual medical
doctor I think dr. oz he's a doctor cuz
he wears those blue that blue outfit he
just bought that at a Halloween store oh
well okay I felt mustache went to
college he did not parent you dirty
crack [ __ ] uh that's the that's the way
I know Ken's a real he really was I
don't think he's a I don't think he was
good at it I mean that's why he went
into entertainment and now ken is very
old and needs work and needs to be needs
to keep his brain going and so I would
talk to him about the coronavirus and
his wife is a practicing doctor Tran
Tran ho really is a practicing doctor
and she this is her hobby has been
infectious diseases and stuff like this
and so I was like we should go talk
about it because Ken's really good at
distilling it and then of course we knew
there would be community questions in
Episode four were you wearing a yet and
so that's yeah we just had Alison Brie
on and she it's cool she's ugly and not
funny um well listen again you're
showing your true nature not a good guy
hmm
you're you're always very busy in
addition to making rap albums in you yep
I got to dropping tomorrow as your hands
doing you also have a Mortal Kombat
movie coming out yes I played Johnny kid
the voice of Johnny Cage I can't play
the actual Johnny Cage that'll be
probably
Ryan Reynolds so then when will we ever
go out to dinner again and have wine and
just chat will that ever happen again
I think restaurants will open and people
will gather again and have wine you and
I will not get together what well we
can't after this you I asked you on my
show and you show up in a bathroom with
headphones on but look this that's you
with you that's you that's a knockoff
you have a respirator here left to help
you
that's my respirator that's that's
getting anyone excited about that I feel
like it just shows you he doesn't stop
he keeps going it's going he's got a
respirator he won't he's amazing we
mentioned this Joel's podcast the
darkest timeline is available wherever
you get your podcasts yeah and be tiger
King and is streaming now on netflix and
i don't think you can help but see it
you must see it I agree go see it I
didn't have much to do with it but I'm
happy to hitch my wagon to it I think
it's a good that's sort of my attitude
about a lot of things in the business
you know that was my attitude about
heroin okay you went too far you're
right you know what you're right all
right I'm ending this because no you
will not go on I'm gonna scratch let's
keep going I feel like this is the only
way I can end any interview this because
when I look in the mirror do you do the
thing I do which is burst out crying and
then hit it no just smash it
no I start I kiss the tips of my fingers
then I go like this and I go I get to be
me I get to be me man the
self-confidence is incredible man you're
just thinking about her right now well I
you know the other thing about zoom is I
can I haven't looked at you once this
interview really I'm looking at me and
you know what's great I get to be me who
are you talking to who are you looking
at I'm just looking at I have an
imaginary crowd I'm in like a stadium